You're watching ColdFusionTV.
Hi, welcome to another ColdFusion video.
Remember Nokia? You know, that
company that used to dominate the mobile phone industry
in the late 90s and early 2000s?
The company that could do no wrong, until of course, it did.
Well, after a swell of unconfirmed whispers and rumors,
the company from Finland is returning in 2017.
As most of you probably know,
Nokia was losing massive market share to Android
and the iPhone in late 2000s,
but refused to get onto the smartphone game early.
When they finally did get into the smartphone game,
they took a gamble and decided to use Microsoft's OS instead of Android.
This, of course, meant that even though Nokia's build quality,
camera, and hardware was pristine,
the main complaint from the users was that there were no apps.
This didn't bode well
for Nokia, and eventually Microsoft
bought the device and Services Division
of Nokia. After this, they ran it straight
into the ground.
Part of this contract between Microsoft and Nokia was that no Nokia branded phones could be released
up to 30 months after the deal.
Now that 30 month period has just passed and
Nokia can create their own devices again
and wear their brand name proudly
According to the website, Know Your
Mobile, there's going to be two models : a
mid-range phone and a flagship handset. The flagship phone is set to go
head-to-head with the Apple iPhone and
the Samsung Galaxy S8.
For those interested in the technical details, the rumors are saying that the flagship
phone is going to have the as yet
unreleased Snapdragon 835 CPU with
6 gigabytes of RAM. Take that with a grain
of salt, of course. So the interesting
thing is, Nokia itself isn't going to be
making the phone, but they kind of are.
I'll explain what I mean in a second. So
Nokia no longer has the manufacturing
facilities to make the phone but they're
going to be collaborating with a
brand-new Finnish company called HMD Global as well as the Taiwanese manufacturer Foxconn.
The reason I said that Nokia kind of is going to be making the phones again is because
HMD Global was actually founded by veteran Nokia executives.
These ex-Nokia employees
founded the company in May 2016 after
purchasing part of Microsoft's mobile
division.
In a press-release, HMD said that they were going to develop, market, and sell the
Nokia branded phones and accessories
while Foxconn is dealing with R&D and manufacturing.
Nokia is going on an
all-out marketing campaign blitz.
This includes contracting the largest
independent advertising firm in the UK,
MOTHER. And I think this is probably the
best part of this story.
More often than not companies screw up major opportunities like this because they
just don't get the marketing and
advertising right. Advertising campaigns
must be memorable and resonate with
potential customers, and has to get that
sales leverage point across clearly.
With previous clients like Google, Microsoft,
Coca-Cola, IKEA, Calvin Klein, the MOTHER advertising agency seems a promising fit for Nokia.
So looking from a broader
perspective I think it's cool that a
bunch of ex-Nokia staff got together and
form their own company, HMD Global, to
take Nokia back from the grave and make
it rise again.
We'll, of course, see what happens, but I'm wishing them all the best.
So that's just a quick summary and
update about Nokia coming back, but if
you want to know exactly what happened
to Nokia in the first place or want
to know about their history I have a
three-part series on this channel about
that exact topic. It's called "The Rise
And Fall of Nokia." I'll leave it in the
description if you want to check it out.
Anyway, thanks for watching guys, and if
there's not a video before the new year,
happy New Year and I hope it's a great
year for you guys.
Cheers, and have a good one.
ColdFusion, it's new
thinking.